what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and it looks like some things are about
to hit the fan and go crazy in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe right now we
are going into Loki season 2 which is
going to have a huge impact on the MCU
so for those fans who haven't been
seeing the connectivity that they've
wanted recently in the MCU you're about
to see it in Loki season 2. now there
are a lot of projects coming out that
are going to connect to each other and
ultimately lead us to Avengers Secret
Wars but there are a few projects that
are going to directly lead to Avengers
the King Dynasty which of course comes
out before Avengers Secret Wars one of
those projects is of course Loki season
2 but another one of those projects is
going to be doctor strange three and for
a while we didn't know where exactly
this project was going to fall in the
MCU timeline however it looks like we
might have just discovered when it's
going to come out and what specifically
it's going to be about and who exactly
the villain is going to be and based off
of what we've heard it makes perfect
sense the continuity is going to be
fantastic and it's really going to set
up the events of the King Dynasty quite
nicely so we'll break down the new info
that we've learned in this video and if
you want to keep up to date on the MCU
and you want to enter our giveaway be
sure to subscribe and leave a comment
down below for your chance to win an
Xbox series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends
items or some DC items we pick one
winner at the end of each month and the
winner gets to pick one item so there
might actually be two huge plot points
to Doctor Strange three and both of
which are awesome if you recall in the
post-credit scene for Doctor Strange in
the Multiverse of Madness Clea showed up
and she told doctor strange that he
caused an incursion and they were gonna
go fix it Doctor Strange agreed and he
went with her as she sliced a hole or a
tear in reality now CLIA is obviously
going to be a part of Doctor Strange 3
and she's going to play an important
role but she is not one of the two main
plot points that we're going to talk
about today the first one is Kang as it
turns out it looks like Kang the
Conqueror a variant of him or maybe even
prime Kang the main Kang is going to be
the villain in Doctor Strange 3. which
if we think about that that makes a lot
of sense if Doctor Strange 3 is going to
tackle incursions which we know it is
and if it's going to tackle the
Multiverse kind of collapsing on itself
and the destruction of it all which
again we know it is then having Kang in
the movie makes perfect sense because he
is ultimately going to be the
destruction of it all him and his
variants are the ones who are either a
trying to fight each other causing
destruction throughout the Multiverse or
B working together trying to conquer the
Multiverse so as incursions begin to
happen and the Multiverse kind of
becomes unstable Doctor Strange is going
to address the problem yes some of it is
going to be Multiverse jumping but the
other problem is going to be Kang the
Conqueror himself now recently on 4chan
an anonymous user posted a few different
leaks and typically we don't really talk
about anything on 4chan however one of
the leaks that he posted just came true
yesterday the leak said that Emma Corin
is playing a very modified version of
Professor Xavier's evil sister Cassandra
Nova in Deadpool 3. and this was posted
in April so many many months ago and
yesterday this was confirmed to be true
by The Insider can we get some toast
also backed up by other insiders like
Alex P over at the cosmic circus so the
leak is confirmed to be true another
thing this person posted was Doctor
Strange 3 is happening with Kang in a
big role setting up their conflict in
King Dynasty Secret Wars so it looks
like Doctor Strange 3 is going to
directly set up Kang Dynasty it might
even be the movie that happens right
before Avengers Kang Dynasty and again
that would make sense and Doctor Strange
3 while he's trying to fix incursions
and essentially save the Multiverse Kang
is going to appear and he will confront
Kane the Conqueror and this is where
it's really all going to start to hit
the fan and this is one of those
projects where it could either be a
variant of Kang or it could be the prime
King himself self or perhaps even both
we could deal with many different
variants in doctor strange 3. but
regardless of whoever it is it's going
to set up Kang Dynasty and what we know
about King Dynasty is that's where
everything is really going to fall apart
and the Avengers aren't exactly going to
win in Avengers Kang Dynasty it's
probably going to be something like we
got with Avengers Infinity war and
Avengers end game in Infinity War The
Avengers lost but in Avengers end game
they came back they Avenged half the
universe and that seems to be what is
going to happen here they'll lose to
King in Kang Dynasty then they'll come
together multiple different teams from
multiple different universes and Avenge
the people who have fallen to Kang
Avenge the other universes and the
Multiverse and restore it to normal this
will most likely be done by either
Doctor Strange or Reed Richards Reed
Richards does it in the comics so if
they take a play from that book it'll be
read but like we've been talking about
Doctor Strange is going to play a huge
role really in everything when it comes
to the Multiverse and that first part is
him and Doctor Strange 3. I'm assuming
that doctor strange is probably going to
prevent one or maybe two maybe three
incursions in Doctor Strange three
that's how he'll win in his movie but
there will be a loss overall and that
loss will probably be him not being able
to actually defeat Prime King this will
lead us into the events of Avengers the
Kang Dynasty where the real battle for
the entire Multiverse will begin Doctor
Strange will probably be about a few
different universes but then in King
Dynasty it's about everything the entire
Multiverse and then of course like I
said The Avengers will most likely lose
then come together as a multiversal team
and defeat Kang in secret Wars but like
I mentioned in the beginning there could
be another really big component to
Doctor Strange 3 and that could be him
revisiting the 838 Universe this could
be absolutely huge and we'll talk about
that in a bit but first big thank you to
bird dogs for sponsoring this video If
you struggle with finding good shorts to
wear ones that actually fit and actually
look good the struggle is over bird dogs
make you look good and they are
extremely comfortable bird dogs are
specifically designed to look slimmer on
the thigh and the leg giving you a
sculpted look and the best part is they
are stretch khaki shorts they do the
exact same thing as Lululemon but they
fit way better most shorts out there
don't fit very well they're pretty
restricting they're stiff the cotton
they use is pretty terrible but bird
dogs fixes this issue by inventing Cloud
knit fabric that looks just like khaki
but stretches so you get a waist Slimmer
fit without having to sacrifice movement
they also use anti-stink sweat weakening
fabric that helps keep you cool and dry
all day long I've personally really
struggled with shorts because I'm not a
tall guy and I'm kind of bulky and I
have not been able to find shorts that
aren't too long that actually allow me
to move but now I have with bird dogs
they are awesome and the best part is if
you order a pair you get a free Yeti
style tumbler so go to birddogs.com
Cosmic for a free Yeti style Tumblr with
your order that's birddogs.com Cosmic
for a free Yeti style tumbler you won't
want to take your bird dogs off we
promise you
yesterday we learned that Cassandra Nova
is going to be one of the main villains
of Deadpool 3 and she is going to seek
revenge on the 616 Universe our main
Avengers Universe because the Scarlet
Witch killed her brother Professor
Xavier and the Illuminati other insiders
have also hinted that yes there is going
to be a conflict between the 838
Universe in which the Illuminati all got
killed by the Scarlet Witch and our
universe the 616. this is supposedly
going to be addressed at some point in
time and it is possible that it could be
addressed in Doctor Strange 3 since he
is going to be trying to prevent
incursions perhaps one incursion that
he's going to have to prevent or one
that he's already caused could be the
838 Universe we don't know which
Universe Cleo was talking about in the
post credit for Multiverse of Madness
but Doctor Strange did visit and heavily
impacted the A3 universe so it would
make sense that he would cause an
incursion in that Universe after all the
most powerful team in that Universe was
taken out this is something that could
definitely cause an incursion and not to
mention in one of the members of the
Illuminati was the smartest man on the
planet Reid Richards that could cause
serious repercussions it also seemed
like they had a pretty good grasp on the
Multiverse as well and perhaps were
preventing incursions themselves from
happening so without them there the
universe is probably not going to be
okay so I'm assuming one of the
incursions is going to be that a38
universe and it looks like some people
in that Universe are gonna have some
beef with Doctor Strange and definitely
the Scarlet Witch so this conflict could
add another layer to the threat of the
Multiverse not only will Kang be trying
to conquer everything and Destroy many
different universes and incursions are a
big threat as well but we're gonna have
another universe that has super powered
people that has the X-Men that has the
Fantastic Four that has some Avengers
super pissed off and want revenge on the
Scarlet Witch and the Earth 616 Universe
for what they did allowing the Scarlet
Witch to get out of control allowing her
to find the dark hole allowing her to
dreamwalk and kill the Illuminati and
cause destruction to their universe most
likely causing an incursion and this
universe the Earth 838 universe is
probably going to collide with the Earth
616 Universe in Avengers Secret Wars we
know universes are going to collide and
I'm betting that this is one of the
universes that is going to fuse with
ours to where both teams are now in the
same universe and there might be some
fighting going on and I actually really
hope there will be because I think that
would just be super cool to see an
Avengers team fighting another Avengers
team that has the X-Men the Fantastic
Four on it that's gonna be cool to see
so I hope it happens but let me know
your thoughts about all of this in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest news you
can also follow us on Instagram and
Twitter as well and as always thank you
all so much for watching woof woof